and Arjen another super strong Indian
teenager what's your experience with him
I mean I only played a couple of games
against him the first was a draw in the
world Blitz and the second was the first
game of the polymers here
um but in his I mean he's amazing
strong
um very good practically as well so he's
he's a very tough opponent as I said
um earlier um
on an earlier day I think he's certainly
a uh top 10 player in the world when it
comes to wrapping blood yeah
and teen you were already 2 800. what
chances do you give Arjun of becoming
a super duper Grandmaster
2 800.
um if I was him I wouldn't Focus too
much on on that
um it's clear that he's uh is improving
he's doing very well
um and um you know he's probably also
gonna
um have challenges at some point
um but um
that they come potentially when playing
against the best in the world and not
before
very very positive and
I'm very curious to see how we will do
also
in other events against against players
yeah first of all excited to see him
probably play you tomorrow best of luck
in the final minus